Ariana Grande might be taking a social
media break after calling it quits with
Pete Davidson I think that me being open
with my fans and my supporters it's like
a very important thing because like it's
like like on Tuesday the singer
addressed the end of her engagement for
the first time she took to Instagram
sharing a now-deleted message about her
involvement in the upcoming wicked TV
special writing quote time to say
bye-bye again to the internet for just a
little bit it's hard not to bump news
and stuff that I'm not trying to see
right now it's very sad and we're all
trying very hard to keep going
[Music]
arianna performed the wizard and i at
the event alongside original cast member
idina menzel but the 25 year old
admitted her anxiety almost got the best
of her before the taping quote can't
believe I almost let my anxiety ruin
this for me today not today Satan not
tomorrow or the next day either finna
sing my heart out and be a big walking
vessel of love I'm very airing but I'm
also like calm private I don't know
despite Ariana and Pete split a source
told et they still love each other
adding they are remaining positive and
looking forward to a future together
where they may be best friends and still
haven't ruled out the possibility of one
day making their relationship work as
Ariana goes social media silent we're
told she still communicates with Pete
following the break-up
[Music]
pop star has stayed out of the spotlight
as of late especially after the sudden
passing of her ex-boyfriend Mac Miller
in September our et source says the
rapper's death had a big impact on her
and Pete was a huge support as she coped
adding the former couple has quote a
very special connection
partly because Pete has been there for
Ariana during a painful time in her life
she will forever and always be grateful
to Pete so no matter what I'm grateful
[Music]